for vice with Barbie kalana and will
second city right there friend Wow
hi Bob sound like that homeless guy with
the really good voice oh the man from
seven years ago yep
hi Bobby kalila my boyfriend I just
broke up after two years he was bipolar
and refused to take medication the
relationship became mentally abusive I
don't have any self esteem anymore your
podcast is the only thing that keeps me
smiling I've listened to every episode
so we were supposed to move to LA
together in September he wanted to
pursue a career in music and I wanted to
pursue fashion and event planning but
that's what I went to school for and
love he has an internship in a music
production set up because of my
connections out there should I tell my
close friend he is going to intern for
about our breakup and our relationship
was really like I think she's trying to
say tell my close friend he's about she
set up the internship interview yeah so
she's asking if she should tell the
people at the internship about his
getting off his medication and basically
sabotaging his move to LA yes well I
mean no more yeah yeah it's the only
person I really know out there I don't
know who else I could live with I don't
know if I could afford to live alone I
just feel like it's really complicated
now and I feel discouraged and about
trying to pursue my own dreams she
dodged a bullet and her the reason that
she's upset is because she's connecting
all of the all of her hopes wants and
dreams to this [ __ ] guy and he's a
zoo you do not want to move to LA with a
bipolar dude who's a musician [ __ ] you
couldn't write that any funnier than
right no that's a disaster that's a
nightmare right America yeah as far as
telling them about telling the people at
the internship whether or not I would
say no cuz just just disassociate with
that and not only that I would be like
all that and get not have them get the
internship no I wouldn't even go that
far I tell you what I'll tell you what
just let me hear my thought though
alright well you didn't hear mine about
stand-up yeah because this is no I have
to write it all right there it's our
we're we good if illicit locate if I was
dating not you but let's say I was did a
group let's make up a name
Sabrina classes to bring it up both
Volkov itch
ooh European yes Sabrina Vukovich well
it's the name of the girl um hey you
know you knew that I made that up right
yeah I did no no I didn't was getting
[ __ ] no I don't get [ __ ]
I'm you receiving no I do not receive it
I'm 43 years old I tell every woman
before I hang out with them that my dick
doesn't work as a matter of fact this is
this is damn true I don't even I don't
kiss on the first date a lot of times
not even the second or a third date I
just want to get to know more kids you
do great dad I wrote you here please ten
said I'm just gonna run off to Canada
build a log cabin yeah you know work
like make candles or something and just
have like seven kids like find a you
know I don't believe in big age gap
relationship yeah but I'm like I'm 43
right so I gotta get so I gotta get like
a 21 year old girl and just just someone
I know can what am I just barren
immaturity machine no I'm but I'm
talking about I want right you want a
fresh product I want eleven kids
yeah yeah I want yeah would you support
that now keep in mind there's not gonna
be a whole there's gonna be even less
time for stand-up I could do the car if
you called me and you said that I would
probably go now that's a mistake
get back here not only that is is that I
I mean and you can PMP I've argued with
people about this before your dream is
your dream din yeah but and when and
when you're our age your drive has an
end it doesn't end
no no it doesn't have to end it's not it
you know what kind of I'm doing better
now there
ever have sure and I want to quit if I
would have quit three years ago it's
talking about Hana in a [ __ ] ranch
yeah making candles that sounds awesome
amazing life I tell you what a couple of
my buddies got back to our hometown
we're from yeah about a couple months
ago I was visiting one of the guys I see
him all the time I tell you they're a
hoot and well I'm driving I'm driving
down the street to my buddy's place yeah
it's like 9 p.m. we're in the you know
Western Canadian suburbs they're outside
of Vancouver yeah and in my hometown and
there's like a couple of little dudes
like 10 years old riding their BMX bikes
the midgets no lights no little dudes
like kids oh and they're riding their
bikes like they don't have any lights
they just have reflectors yeah less [ __ ]
on their bikes than the stranger things
kids right and they're just riding their
bikes down the street uh-huh at nine
o'clock yeah there's no rapists or
killers or pedophiles in Canada uh-huh
right yeah don't you want to raise your
kids there and they make some candles I
see the soy candles thirty years later
right what are they doing making soy
candles know their kids are riding their
[ __ ] bicycles from the motorbikes
yeah they're now and they're a [ __ ]
they're in the health and they're doing
math I'm sorry to interrupt anyway this
this lady what my point was is that you
know if I was going going out with a
woman by name of Sabrina Malkovich Yeah
right
classic thank you and she was bipolar
and we broke up and I got her entered
job internship shut job somewhere of a
different City Comedy Store in my head
yeah Comedy Store in my head was like
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] bipolar she could
snap right shoot up [ __ ] the place
and that's not gonna be good or it's
also gonna reflect poorly on you yeah or
poorly on me yeah so um pull it pull it
what a great podcast you only take one
question yeah [ __ ] you you talking
everybody and is she one lucky listener
one lucky listener again
[Music]